several studies suggest that natural
immunity the antibodies your body
produces when you recover from covid
offer stronger protection than any of
the corona vaccines so why force
vaccines on people who've recovered from
covid and have those antibodies jeffrey
jerry is the senior vice president of
medical and academic affairs at st louis
university hospital which is allowing
employees with natural impunity to defer
taking the kovid shot for a year he
joins us to explain
mr jerry thanks i appreciate you coming
on doctor this seems like a sensible
science-based solution
why isn't everyone doing it but tell us
why are you doing this
we're doing it because we're following
the science it's important for us to
state that we're absolutely committed to
vaccination and we're also absolutely
committed to actually
mandating it in health care it's very
different in healthcare than other
businesses but with that in mind those
of us who make this decision not only
took into account what was going on
nationally and internationally like the
israeli study but more to the point
those of us who make that decision were
not doing this behind the desk or behind
a computer or actually seeing patients
and we knew that even once the delta
variant had hit that it was very
apparent to us that those individuals
who had a verified natural infection
were at least
as protected if not better protected
than those who had gotten two shots of
an mrna vaccine or a single shot of the
j j vaccine so we offered this deferment
and it is a deferment we don't know how
long it's going to last but as the data
actually accumulates we'll change our
policy in accordance with the science so
you're you're using number science
that's available to the cdc as well so
why aren't they recommending the same
well i can't speak for the cdc and in
fact
we do support giving a single dose of an
mrna vaccine
after
getting natural immunity because we know
that it increases your protection by
tenfold the cdc unfortunately is still
insisting on two doses of an
mrna vaccine and we don't think that
that actually is supported by the
science that we look at and again we're
practicing doctors and we're able to
interpret it that way
do you think that they have are they
looking at difference just for non the
non scientists watching including me do
you think they have different data sets
they're looking at are you looking at
the same numbers
i think that we're all looking at
different data sets uh there is we do
not adhere to a bureaucracy we've always
been very adherent to collaboration and
communication and making decisions very
quickly based on what is proper for our
patient population and for our staff and
their families and that's what we've
done so i think when you have government
agencies it tends to work in a slower
fashion
yeah apparently dr jerry thanks so much
for coming on i appreciate st luke's
hospital in my pleasure
appreciate it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else